[Music]
stronger yet no intro today couldn't
think of anything so strong as a movie
starring Jake Gyllenhaal he plays Jeff
Bowman who was a victim of the Boston
Marathon bombing he lost both of his
legs in those bombings so this is the
story of his road to recovery
essentially recovery despair depression
stages of acceptance one thing I want to
illustrate right now is this movie is
not a movie about the Boston Marathon
bombing there was a movie like that it's
called Patriots Day it's very good it
came out last year this is the movie
about one person it's this very personal
journey here what I liked about it is it
takes all the pomp and circumstance out
of it no a lot of stories or news
coverage like oh those guy was a hero he
got through that cuz he's very strong
he's Boston strong in fact he is
stronger this movie's not really like
that the colorful banners and [ __ ] the
headlines they exist in this movie but
it shows how he reacts to it he really
didn't want this spotlight but Jake
Gyllenhaal gives another great
performance he shows us what he's made
of he's shown as many times before this
is just another scenario where you look
at the guy you're like you're one of the
better actors working he shows a lot of
vulnerability in this movie this movie's
actually more about the vulnerability or
to rephrase the fact that vulnerability
makes strength go Jake Gyllenhaal comes
across is so like about the beginning
that when this happens to him you're
like we're pulling for you man
Tatiana maslany plays his girlfriend
they're kind of on again off again but
she is one of the people you see this
thing has greatly affected her also and
although she is kind of a rock for him
an inspiration for him it ain't easy for
her either and they completely shows and
she was also very good in this movie one
thing this movie does that I found
interesting but is also a strength and a
weakness is the fact that it illustrates
that when one thing like this happens to
somebody it's not just the somebody
everyone around them it affects them too
they may not have lost their legs but
they are greatly affected by this also
talking about how much it concentrated
on the family and there is a large
family I felt like showing so much of
the family though there was a point and
purpose in the eyes of the filmmaker I
felt like showing so much of them
detracted from Jeff Bowman's personal
story kind it does seem like a conundrum
or at least a contradiction to say how
much they showed the family in this
movie was an interesting dynamic of it
but then turn around and say how much
they showed the family actually
detracted all things in moderation
though I found it interesting that they
did show that dynamic I felt like they
could have shown a little less of them
did you walk away from this movie on
bit of a downer no because it's
interesting in the unconventional way
that it was seeing the realistic
frustrated take of recovery for someone
it feels like a lot of downward spiral
for a lot of the movie and then at a
point at the end he's like yeah I got
hope and in the movie end I feel like I
could have gone for a montage of some
sort of him and recovery show him
crawling out of the despair that they
took so much time setting up if you give
me this much frustration and anger give
me at least that much optimism but it
does end on the optimistic note so you
do take that with you guys in the end
stronger was very interesting it's sad
it's tragic it's crushing it's
thoughtful is heartfelt and above all is
very realistic I walk away from this
movie glad I watched it I will say
stronger is worth watching no alcohol
required alright guys so stronger have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite movie of someone
overcoming an obstacle whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]